on this Memorial Day Weekend more than
81 thousand Americans remain missing
from World War II the Korean War Vietnam
and the Cold War and another six who
served in more recent conflicts in the
Middle East are also unaccounted for
that is where the work Begins for one
division of the defense department as
Mark Strassman shows us their mission is
to ensure every missing American Service
member comes home
America keeps Faith with its unknowns at
Arlington National Cemetery this revered
ritual salutes service members killed in
action but never identified
known but to God we won't leave you
behind it doesn't matter if it's been 80
years or yesterday we make that promise
to you Carrie Brown's a forensic
anthropologist with a dpaa the defense
p-o-w-m-i-a accounting agency at this
lab near Omaha and another on Oahu
scientists try to solve puzzles
identifying hundreds of remains each a
nameless service member killed in combat
each forensic case typically takes years
they rely on DNA dental records sinus
records and chest x-rays this Nebraska
lab has 80 tables of remains and
personal effects in January 1945 This
b-17s Crew went down in a German field
with five Mias one died wearing this
wedding ring the poignant moments is
when you're looking at items that a
person had on them when they died when
this life changing event occurred
life-changing for him for his entire
family for generations to come Judy
Wade's family knows all about
generational grief my granddaddy just
never would let that go he never would
let go of the fact that his baby had
gone off to war and died
and didn't come home Army Corporal
Luther story her uncle killed in Korea
on September 1st 1950. stories backstory
a true war hero
during one battle in Korea his army
citation says he killed or wounded 100
enemy Soldiers the 18 year old died
protecting his unit one called him the
bravest soldier I ever met
story earned the Medal of Honor General
Omar Bradley presenting it to story's
father did you give up hope
no but for decades stories remains when
unidentified like hundreds of sailors
killed aboard the USS Oklahoma when a
capsized during the attack on Pearl
Harbor when we can put a face to the
remains do you get even more connected
to what you're doing Carrie lagarde's
team identified 362 sets of remains from
the ship and returned them to their
families including the Barber Brothers
Malcolm Leroy and Randolph their mother
received this photo taken aboard ship
weeks after they were killed it's hard
not to be emotional about what happened
to them and you know and what they went
through and what their families went
through these Sailors killed on the day
that began World War II for the U.S
identified in the same building where
1940s workers built the Enola Gay the
bomber that ended the war since 2015 the
dpaa has identified nearly 12 100
soldiers Sailors Airmen and Marines
remains returned from 45 countries and
Judy Wade after 73 years the family
finally got word last month Luther's
story has been identified it must have
been blown away oh gosh it was like
every every brain cell I had was like
that it exploded in my head did your
heart skip a beat my whole body did I
always had a fantasy when I was a child
that he really hadn't died that somehow
he had survived and someone had taken
care of him one day
he was going to come home but even now
you say that and there's a catch in your
throat well
he is coming home now
on Monday Memorial Day Luther's story
will be laid to rest in Andersonville
Georgia an American promise kept for CBS
Saturday morning I'm Mark Strassman
ooh the commitment of those people to
bring everyone home
underestimate the value of what that is
to those families of being able to have
them home yeah you could see it on her
face the closure even after all these
years for these families all 1200 of
them